we were in New York and we saw this
thing called the pagan bat it wasn't a
being advertised so what pagan diet
again okay hey Leo Plus plant-based diet
with small amounts of animal protein and
we were like you mean food you know so
one of my friends is a woman named EC
Santos ki and she's optimized me
nutrition and she has this notion first
things first let's improve the caloric
density of your diet by getting you to
eat 800 grams of vegetables and fruits a
day 800 grams just hit that mark me so
that's how far away we're having a
conversation about is this movie about
being plant-based good or bad I'm like
hey I eat meat and eggs and cheese and
all these other things but I also get
800 grams of vegetables and fruits or a
kilo of vigils of fruits a day that's my
base are you able to stick to around the
piece of cake
I'd salad for breakfast I a palm full of
blueberries is 80 grams so what you're
seeing is oh you know we we villainized
fruit right yeah I'm like seriously you
think and act like eating to apples is
really the limiting factor to your
performance today what are you gonna eat
instead you know like a protein shake
highly processed impossible burger
I'm joined by the super leopard himself
mr. Kelly Starrett Kelly welcome to the
show
it is a pleasure to be be back on the I
don't know I say it's a better side of
the the ocean but I do have an affinity
okay
yeah man are you with me now you're
adopted for the next hour we're going to
be talking about whatever we talk about
you can be British for a little while
get a cup of tea up in the borough
market and then also assassins role so
if you can make that happen
that's like knowledge but that's you
dropping your peak UK knowledge box
isn't it that was the most
quintessentially British thing I can
think of it's a cup of tea my role
that's right that's right
so how are you man it's awesome to see
you again
follow your stuff I'm sure a lot of
people that are listening will be as
well you guys been super busy recently
you know here's the deal we try to treat
our thinking about human beings and our
lives as a game you cannot win all you
can do is sort of play better and better
and better and to that end if you if you
treat your fitness your wellness your
health like a game with clear and clear
clear winners and losers you know what
all the rules are you're a fool I mean
that's that's the same in business the
same and raising kids
these are open-ended tasks and we have
always reserved the right to get better
and to refine our thinking into and to
think differently and critically about
the needs of the people we serve and to
that end you know we just applied that
same amount of thinking to to our
business and what we we had is 10 years
of experience helping people improve
pain helping people take a crack at
moving more efficiently more effectively
and the things that they loved and we're
trying to get the physio and the doctor
out of the conversation because frankly
so much of this of what we're working on
is is disruptive in the way that hey
this is a part of the language of being
a human being the same way that you
don't have to talk to nutritionists we
have lunch right you don't have to talk
to your doctor or you know before you go
to bed I mean it's crazy that they're
divorced muscle skeletal health and care
and understanding
you know from our environmental
lifestyle selves and now we're trying to
fix that so what we what we realize is
that people were a lot more clever than
we have originally given them credit for
and I mean we've always assumed that
people were more clever but I don't
think that our traditional industries
have necessarily and to that end you
know we rebranded and changed our the
user experience and user interface and
we went from mobility wad which was
really confusing for people
mobility now means nothing and wad is a
you know as a technical term that has
been sort of co-opted by lots of
companies like sobriety wide and faith
laud and mentality wad and then we
really felt like what we were doing was
trying to help people in the context of
their lives did as ready as they could
for whatever they want to get ready for
and I've been talking about this notion
of this ready state which is sort of
saying you can't live in a you're not a
monk you have family obligations and
private previous history of injuries and
maybe play the sport and maybe you have
a job that forces us to stay awake
sometimes at hot hours so how could how
ready can we get you what can we control
which is really a different idea around
hey I've got a box of a hundred things
and if I don't check off my list of a
hundred things and somehow failure and I
haven't bio hacked or optimized and
instead we're saying this hey look let's
play a more beautiful game and that was
really the birth of the ready state
that's awesome I mean a lot of people
will be familiar with mobility words I
think you're right the opportunity for
you to expand out from a term which is
obvious but perhaps a little
constrictive in that mobility just
focuses on that to the ready state which
is something that seems a little bit
more holistic so what how would you
define the difference between what you
were doing before and what you're doing
now with regards to what you provide
well you know I think people forget that
when we started this project you know
ten years ago you know the iPhone didn't
have a video camera so you know YouTube
was a nascent emergent thing and you
know I we were on blogger was original
platform and you know we didn't set out
to make a library that ended up
feeling like the like the out library of
alexandria with 4000 videos we set out
to raise the bar and give people the
tools to be able to take a crack at
fixing themselves and making themselves
feel better and improving their movement
efficiency and one of the things that i
think it's in there it's it's confusing
for people is mobilizing is a tool to
restore your position and for example
one of the reasons I don't think
stretching ever really took off I mean
we've even known to stretch your whole
life I mean your football coach and they
just stretch it cetera et cetera right
but athletes don't do things that don't
work and when an athlete perceives poor
value a poor return on value they drop
it out and I we saw that and of course
stretching can be a large and nebulous
term but all we saw was no we came out
of a physio but I'm a coach first and if
you ask me sit me down airplane I'm
gonna say I'm a coach and then I'm like
I'm also a physio and into that end you
know part of the magic of what we're
trying to do here is always to say hey
look it's movement first and our
movements cues come from the language of
gymnastics and powerlifting and Olympic
lifting and bodyweight control and
there's a lot of cueing and
understanding around sport that these
coaches have discovered what is the best
expression of human physiology what are
the shapes that are the most powerful
one of the positions and skills and cues
that give us the most robust and most
stable person and underline that then is
that mobilizations really end up Frost
becoming position transfer exercises if
you can't put your arm over your head
that's a problem and no matter no matter
like how much there's no compensation
you do or magical thing you do if it's a
tissue restriction that's a tissue
assertion and people get stiff that's
okay so what are the tools to restore
that so that's the piece but well first
half of you know two-thirds of sup a
leopard it's really about how to move
and move more efficiently and then
Tiny's movement principles in the
foundations of strength conditioning and
when we begin to layer on additionally
the fact that you know the gym is the
greatest place on earth to be to work on
your weaknesses to work on painful
positions to talk about nutrition sleep
and stress to be a member of a tribe and
community to be
seeing we have all the aspects the
biopsychosocial model which people have
been saying oh we've got to look at it's
not just your knee it's how you exist in
society and I'm like a little crap what
do you think we do at the gym we if you
show up and you're a hot mess because
you haven't slept any but newborn and
you're super stressed that's immediate
to us and that's part of this language
of conversation when someone's injured
we keep them engaged in our community we
don't cut them out of their tribe like
we keep them as part of that community
and and so that they feel safe they feel
secure that they're they're still a
member of a group and we still exercise
and we talk about nutrition so what's
really happening is that you know it's
easy for people to say even in the term
ability people think oh I'm squatting
that I'm working my mobility I'm like no
you're just squatting right ultimately
what we're saying is do you have full
access to your physiology as a human
being yes or no and then what are your
tools to maintain that and then optimize
that and we're gonna have to talk about
your tissue quality and we're gonna have
to talk about all the other things that
matter to you in the context of your
life guess what that's called
strengthing auditioning that's called
getting my 14 year old team of swimmers
ready to compete right homework stress
boys it doesn't matter what the what the
demands are ultimately we're trying to
recognize that human beings are existing
in these lives and the things that we
sort of presented on Instagram is a
false reality of what's possible and the
way we should be living so what are the
minimum effective doses and more
importantly how do I get people to be
able to feel when they're out of
position or they need to change or
something hurts so they actually have a
plan because people got very
sophisticated but they're eating they're
very sophisticated but they're training
but they're not sophisticated about
recognizing that bringing your knee to
your chest is the root component of
squatting or kettlebell swings yeah it's
interesting you talk about the
biopsychosocial model when it comes to a
gym I recently did a podcast with
Douglas Murray who wrote the madness of
crowds and in that he identifies the
fact that we've had this loss of grand
narrative as he calls it the fact that
the modern the modern era might be the
first generation of people who have no
reason or no idea wider on
planet we've had a drop away with
regards to religion the typical
community that you would've had locally
has now been opened up because people
can make connections online we no longer
have such quite typical jobs for life
anymore
etc etc etc and I often think about
myself the fact that I enjoy training so
much I've enjoyed exercising since I was
a kid and I feel so fortunate that that
is a pathway and a mechanism which is
inside of me because if I didn't have
that if I wasn't able to go to the gym
and I didn't have the support structure
of the people who are at the gym and
people who were like me they have
similar interests to me they want to
make themselves better all that sort of
stuff if it wasn't for that I I'd be
half the human that I think I am that
outlets that support structure
everything is more than just the
movements that you're doing in the gym
it's everything else and I think that
really helps to compensate for what we
might be seeing with this loss of ground
narrative you know we try to remind
people so for example you know we have
looking at a coach who's been coaching
here for 12 or 13 years we've grown up
together you know we if we're in a class
together I took her crutch takes my
class we still shake hands like it's the
first time and part of that is being
seen
part of that is saying I hey I see you
and I appreciate that we're here
together and that acknowledgement so we
shake hands every single time even in
people that I've been training for over
a decade coaching for over a decade
right we've been coaching me we still
pretend like it's the first time it's
also maybe the only time where people
are getting any unconditional positive
regard you know and why I think training
in a group is so important
and while the gym the traditional gym is
just look I don't care what your reason
is for your health and training and
whatever but that gym is isolating and
lonely and the short story is that human
beings are what's most important and
when we spend more time with other human
beings in a way where we're supporting
and coaching for example one of the
things that sometimes I've heard in the
past is that coaches don't like athletes
to self coach you know they don't like
the coat and I'm like that's nonsense
the idea is to be able to have people be
so competent that they can have these
really tight feedback loops and
mechanisms
within the in the structure of the group
training environment so it's not one
coach shouting its coaches and athletes
having these small conversations and
self-correcting and making modifications
and and being being party to a greater
conversation you know we said we always
get back together we always point out a
star Baker in the class which is
actually the truth like I'm like you are
the star Baker you know the Great
British baking show you know that show
the star Baker yeah from the Great
British baking should I've been to what
people bringing in cupcakes or is that
the performance of the day oh that's
that's that's the person who I thought
was move the best or you know shut up
right and so we have this with this
notion where we also look each other a
good job and someone someone is
recognized your effort and we try to
build these feedback loops which are you
know cognitive social feedback loops
were just as important as making gains
on your squat right what we want people
to recognize is this has to be the only
place where you can completely fall on
your face the gym is the only place
where you can show up trashed and say
I'm here and you're gonna be safe you
can expose your weakness or the suppose
your old injury you know your ability to
generate force breathe hard even your
range of motion is a moving target if
you don't believe me let's go take a
red-eye and we'll fly across the country
you know cross the ocean and we'll
measure you the next day and see how you
do and you're gonna see that your your
crap and that's okay and so what we want
people that recognize is that the
training stimulus is also the diagnostic
tool how am I feeling what's going on
how does this fit in the context and I
if I'm a maintenance trane
physiotherapist which is an Australian
model of manual therapy and thinking
about a systems approach to the body but
the original Maitland model is I would
see someone for an injury three to five
times a week if you imagine that physio
five times a week imagine in fact are
the follow-up questioning is like well
how did you feel after the first hour
after I saw you how did you feel after
the first 12 hours and then how'd you
for first thing in the morning because
I'm seeing the next day and those
feedback mechanisms really tight and
then my treatment would be predicated on
the next thing who what medical
professional do you see five times a
week
you don't you have to have something
very wrong with you to be heretical
irrational and and we're having a
conversation but you might see your
coach or your training partners three to
five times a week right so we have to
reconsider they it doesn't mean I'm
injured but also night sweats dizziness
people vomiting nausea unaccounted for
weight loss weight gain changes by our
bowel function right commonly problem we
cough sneeze or swallow those are red
flags and everyone in our gym can smell
out that hey I don't think you're just
sore you've got something going on
you've got a fever and there's some
disease let's go get to talk to medical
official also you can't occupy your own
society you can't do your job can't play
your role on this team or there's a bone
sticking out of your leg or you've got
you know rabies of the knees you are
injured and you need to get out of here
and the rest of it though our coaches
own it are our staff our athletes right
that it's a normal experience to come in
with the patina of injury with what the
fact that you're stiff or you you you
know you came out of a bad soccer match
when you were 14 and you that ankle gets
stiff sometimes or you just overdone it
because you're a meathead and you're you
know and you and she and she loves to do
back-to-back triathlons that's totally
fine but in this place we actually have
well one safe place and to your point it
may be the only way that I'm not on jail
I'm not on drugs because I figured out
that I can self-medicate with exercise
and I found a community of people that
said I'll be there for you tomorrow
that's that's that's the new church I
think it is I think it is and I feel
very sorry for people who do not have
that natural pull towards exercise to
your point about the gym on its own this
is something I've mentioned about before
but some of the listeners it was a long
time ago I first brought this up I'd be
interested to hear your thoughts on it
as well so I came up with something when
I was probably around about 26 27 and I
called it the fitness menopause and what
it felt like to me was a change in my
body what my body was there to do and it
may meant that I'd spent
years training purely for aesthetics all
I was bothered about was going into the
gym steeping in my own neuroses
as I had their head the headphones in
I'm looking in the mirror talking to
myself despite being in a gym surrounded
by people not talking to any of those
people except for may have you finished
on that venture can I take your plates
blah blah and then very quickly I think
as I was like on 2728 and as you begin
to approach 30 you become chronically
aware of your own mortality you're also
a little bit less bothered about maybe
purely training for aesthetics so I
decided to make the change I switched
across to CrossFit and as this byproduct
of that bizarrely my condition got
better I actually ended up in better
condition than had been before because I
was enjoying my training but my body's
makeup my body composition was no longer
the purpose for my training and
externalized that to my performance and
so many people so many of my friends now
I'm seeing that have been like maybe
little Instagram stars or whatever these
say bro lifters and they get twenty
seven twenty eight twenty I'm watching
my watch going it's [ __ ] coming it's
coming foot and then sure enough bang
they start doing parkour runs five K's
on a morning on a Sunday morning every
single Sunday they're doing that Darren
who's one of my buddies is doing that
another one of the guys will start doing
some swimming a lot of guys I'm doing
and I'll do an open water swimming
because they've found some pole through
that as well and it's so interesting
that you have this move away from what
is essentially bolstering perhaps their
lack of self-confidence or obviously is
exercise but what that made me reflect
on was so many people especially young
guys particularly they take a route to
bodybuilding their first port of call
because the barriers to entry are so low
but people spend their entire lives
doing snatch in a clean and jerk that's
it whole life like a career take me into
a gym I can do a probably a moderately
competent bicep curl within about two
minutes
like it's so simple right and I just you
know that was something that I'd thought
of a long time ago and I really do
applaud CrossFit and these more public
weightlifting gyms that are now coming
across to the UK as well for creating a
community that forces people to talk if
you're doing a partner workout you have
to talk to the person that's with you
nan trains in a CrossFit gym with the
headphones in everyone's talking no no
it's important to recognize how
that that is not a sustainable model
right that go and put your headphones in
put your head down taking selfies he
works for a minute but also it's you
inherit the system and what you're
seeing is that people are products in an
environment approximate system and and
it takes a minute to two ways or
consciousness and and people come to
consciousness at different phases I so
here's an example my daughter Georgia is
fourteen
she plays Marcie water polo she has
grown up right and she has enough school
on Friday she said is hey can we go into
the gym with my mates I'd like to go
jump into a class so I've been waiting
for fourteen years for her to say that
and you it takes a minute to plant the
seed yeah it takes a minute to look
around and say hey is there a better way
and this model of training on the
Internet its nascent its developing its
it's less than fifteen years old
and the notion of sort of sharing
kettlebells is very Russian and if you
came out of a track-and-field tradition
if you came out of you know its petal
belly so our kettlebell traditional and
Olympic lifting tradition you had
training partners and engaged in a
training hall in a training environment
and that was because you just lucked
into a community that already engaged
and valued these things this is how we
get together how we train you know in
the United States I think we have a
concentrated relationship with American
football right and one of the reasons
it's complicated is we recognize that
it's it's dangerous and it's potentially
splits or Sochi act on socio-economic
lines but the reason I have come to
believe that it still exists is it's the
only time that young men in America were
ever on a team ever where they were ever
you know it didn't matter what your size
was there was a role for you it didn't
matter what your capacities wasn't role
for you and even if you were a backup
and you just supported the team's will
scout off and scout defense you it's
you're still such a valuable member of
the team and it's painful and you hurt
together and that those things are one
of the reasons that small group training
or being in a running club or swimming
group
really really matters and again you know
to your point hopefully we'll all see
that there is a better way and the world
has changed we try to remind people that
when we started this thing this November
is our official 14th year of being a gym
14 years and we started a year before
that so you know we've been doing this
for a minute have you money got you have
you managed to hold on to your same
affiliation from the very start are you
still paying like 300 dollars a year or
whatever it was I like to 20 dollars a
year it's 500 dollars a year well that's
probably about like 3,500 less than most
years now you know we we took you know
where we're now officially the 21st
cross in the world and I'll tell you the
style of training that we do it's core
values remain the same as 15 years ago
the difference is we are so much more
sophisticated why because we've all
evolved because we now are hanging out
with way more when people if there's no
Olympic athletes and the explosion so
that the training but its core value is
that we show up we train together we
play together we compete together right
we expose faults everyone is down one of
the things that I try to do with a lot
of coaches is I'm this is my
mother-in-law there she is right Oh 75
in March that's right so you know the
short story is we're getting better and
better at tweaking refining training
well I try to remind people hey look you
couldn't buy a kettlebell in San
Francisco 15 years ago we had to drive
down the Santa Cruz we had to drive 2 or
3 hours of my kettle balls in the entire
city
you know Diane foo is an incredible
Olympic lifting coach she and I used to
drive to South San Francisco to train
with the only Olympic lifting coach in
the city named Jim Schmitz you know and
we were in this basement and you
couldn't buy Olympic something she was
like the world has changed you know I'm
sitting here looking at one of my staff
and who was an all-american hammer
thrower in track and field and he grew
up
he grew up overhead squatting we did not
and we all came to that late in 15 years
ago I'm like you know people like over
in squats I'm like what were you over at
school honey ten years ago you weren't
your doing came across overs and you
were doing what you know what Muscle &
Fitness told you to get bulky and now
it's okay for us to say we're a little
bit better but the core value is hey
human performance high performance has
told us this are the best ways to eat in
fuel here's the best ways to down
regulate and recover here's the best
ways to feel connected to other human
beings here's the best ways to warm up
here's the best ways to look at your
minimums and I'll be honest I really
feel like physiotherapy is chasing and
even medical issues chasing what
strength condition now has become which
is a really complete physical practice
and a place to to to remedy the holes in
people's lives by making them give a
member of the tribe and then also
developing practices which are super
sustainable I mean no one in here
is ever too skilled a squatter you know
as you get older you care a little bit
less I mean I just PR to my deadlift not
very long though 46 I'm 46 years old
it's taken me this long to understand
dead lifting like now I feel like oh I
really understand what I'm doing before
as a kid I was just doing it right and
so what's nice then is we should be able
to continue to then engage in a mall
we've always believed in which is let's
make performance and training that just
circus let's let's make it matter so
that we can go back to our children we
can go talk to our mother-in-law about
eating more vegetables and fruits and
trying to sleep more and drink less
alcohol and manage what you can manage
because we know you know as to your
point we're gonna be 110 years old that
is on the horizon and if you can get to
60 or 70 today chances of you being a
hundred are very very good and you know
the idea now is if you're gonna be a
hundred years old because of modern
medical technology because of the way we
can keep people alive
I mean you've all her re has said it all
you know where we are going to be
immortal here in a second not immortal
immortal right
and that means we need to be thinking
about this much longer game what does it
look like when I'm forty to fifty and
sixty what as much physical practice
look like how do I take care of mine how
do I take care of brain all those things
are gonna have to be part of our
conversation because we're not gonna die
one or sixty and we're gonna continue to
work and want to train and play yeah so
I did a podcast with dr. David Sinclair
from Harvard Medical School and I asked
him the question do you think humans
will ever live to a thousand years and
he said yeah eventually we're gonna get
there which was a an interesting answer
I mean if you PR and you deadlift it a
thousand years old that'll be
interesting but and so yeah I totally
get it man it is um I wonder how many
people that that really need to start
having a passion with regards to fitness
and training have been brought into a
gym like yours and have found have found
a passion that they never really thought
that they had before with this this
community that they've got going on and
one of the things that strikes me I've
spoken to dr. Quinn henyk from jogger
training systems
I've spoken to mutual friend of ours dr.
Stu McGill spoken to Brian Carol you
know only last week had the guys from
strong first on as well and everyone is
constantly updating that OS everybody
all the time they're always learning new
things and integrating them and stuff
like that so over the last 10 years or
so actually how long super Lapid binos
it's seven years something like that six
years cool so since that's come out what
would you say are some of the headline
changes or new pieces of information or
new philosophies that you've found with
regards to either training or mobility
new information you've come across
anything come to mind well you know I
think what we got a lot right and that
was because that wasn't not based on
thousands and thousands and thousands of
hours of experience in grad school and
lifetime being an athlete and all the
coaches and McGill you know I had
Stewart McGill's book in the loo when I
was a physio student and I read it
cover-to-cover 20 times
he's a real deal man he's the real deal
and you know and so you know I think one
things that we've realized as hey we
need to package this so it's easier for
people we we need to make sure that
they're not missing components we've
been talking about breathing forever
it's in the first notes have I ever put
out and of course I started teaching
2008 what realized there was even more
low-hanging fruit around how we can use
the breath to dreg get down regulate or
use the breath to find the limits of the
range at the fullest breath and the
smallest breath we can use breathing to
us assess our ability to get into good
positions and even pressurize for
maximal lifts so I think what we've done
is realized that you know hey there's
some things that are less effective
there's some mobilizations don't do a
lot of because we just don't need them
right there happened to haven't solved a
lot of problems for us and there are
things that we found to be a lot more
effective and so what you know over time
you know you strip away what isn't
essential and we will continue to do
that so you know VFR blood flow
restriction occlusion training was not
really a thing ten years ago of course
it was katsu has been around forever you
know realizing what a powerful tool it
was the tools of being able to
desensitize and how we've thought about
who's responsible for pain you know
that's a big big deal you know how do I
you know have a gym full of 400 people
be able to make themselves feel better
you know and giving those tools so that
they can take those back to moms and
dads they take the kids and tech you
know they become the combat medic and
you know in a safe in a safe and
responsible way but what we've done is
we really wreak inception alized sort of
the world in physio and the medical
professional and the role of the coach
and the athlete and the person and what
we're seeing is that they do overlap of
course but there's a lot more from the
coach person side who they're just
capable and the world has changed so you
know you can people are cooking their
meat on the bone and eating collagen
again and you know you know the you know
we're seeing people actually move away
believe it or not from protein shakes
and protein bars to back to this thing
called food who'da thought it it's
better for you some of it is we're all
engaged in a grand experiment and the
greatest thing that's happened
this fundamental notion amongst the
Masters like McGill is test-retest and
share you'll see that the brightest
minds on the planet never throw shade
they don't attack people's techniques
then they're like hey what problem
they're trying to solve is that a better
tool than the current tools that I have
and what's nice about that is you stop
it you know this is my my dance space is
not coming through hardstyle we get
about the business of solving problems
and it's okay to have different
different tools and tactics that's okay
to disagree on that but you know you
need to start showing your work like for
example right now there's this team
there's a little world series going on
and I currently work with only two teams
in professional baseball one of them is
the Nationals and the other one is the
Astros and they're both playing each
other but and I'm not saying I have any
part to do with that but it's pretty fun
that I get to test my principles yeah at
the highest levels of baseball Nick Gill
is a head strength conditioning coach
for the All Blacks they're doing pretty
well on the World Cup right now they've
been using our stuff and readystate for
a long time right Nick's a good mate of
mine do I have anything to do their
success no but I get to test my theories
and principles against them and see if I
can support them and make them more
efficient so at some point I need to see
your Olympic medals I need to see your
associations I need to see what groups
you're in I need to see how you think of
public health I need to see that you
one-on-one is great but that I'm
interested now in this notion of social
justice and do your do your models and
an idea scale because if we can't begin
to walk this back to high school and
walk it back to middle school and walk
it back to elementary school then we're
just perpetuating the same old [ __ ]
that we've done where people show up
poorly prepared down-regulating eating
like crap on the internet not not in a
physical culture not tied to a group of
people and then we start backing out of
that and that's a much more difficult
conversation so you know this has got to
be about public health this has got to
be about you know this sounds so cheesy
the original valve the Bodhisattva is
like dude if you're a coach you're
working to make sure that all people are
better movers better athletes better
people that's
central turning of the coach it sounds
like and I will say that the best
athletes and the best excuse me the best
coaches in the world all they're they're
like they'll call you up you can call
them up they'll help you know there's
there's no [ __ ] talk amongst the best
because they're too busy working I
couldn't agree more
having been very fortunate to have
shared either oxygen or bandwidth with
some of the smartest people on the
planet over the last 18 months everyone
that I speak to is they're so concerned
with trying to come together with even
me to walk away from the conversation
knowing more than they came into it
absolutely everyone has this insatiable
hunger for improving themselves and the
people that are around them like Street
McGill doesn't I asked him before I'll
say oh I took a photo together I'll tell
you on Instagram and blah blah and I was
like oh you might you might see it once
it goes up and he's I don't I don't have
Instagram I don't do this all that he's
concerned about all the doctor McGill's
bothered about is trying to focus on his
work and do the thing that's in hand and
yeah the best guys in the world they
don't do that we live my particular
industry to zero-sum game it's a very
very small market about ten thousand
twelve to fifteen thousand people and it
means that if someone is going to your
event they're not coming to my event and
vice versa and I'm seeing that kind of
mentality globally it's like this seven
billion people there are a noticeable to
scarcely there's a scarcity mindset you
know and in the internet is a confusing
place you know I go on Instagram and
really trying to understand what I see
and I see a lot of Jim [ __ ] I see a
lot of waste of time and that's okay
I'll never comment on it right and it's
not that I think that you know we can't
be more efficient more effective but I
really try to understand what problems
people are trying to solve and then
evaluate critically what's happening and
and it takes a minute it takes context
you have to show your associations we
want you to talk about you know the
people who are influenced you and where
you came from and it's okay
it doesn't make you less you know and
that's okay that's you know this is a
this is a newish market right it's a new
field and it's only been around for 10
or 15 years which
has it's gonna take a second for those
things to eat you know to equalize and
the cream will always rise to the top we
saw or listened to jay-z talking about
excellence right and he's like
definition of excellence is performing
at a high level for a really long time
like a decade and being hot means that
you're really popular for a year - he's
like and most things are not you know
conflated they're not the same thing and
so we sell out people get hot and it's
super hard to be around for a decade
you know Mike Boyle has been around a
long time you know he must be doing
something right or he's managed to fool
are we that dumb that we can't tell that
something works or doesn't work is that
what you're selling and it may be that
this is all placebo and belief effect
and I'm willing to say that you know but
I'm also willing to say is there a
better way show me a better model and
show me a rationale for that thinking
that way and that's okay it's okay to
disagree on those things but I need to
know your rationale but you shouting at
me on the Internet nothing childish my
dad's always show me your work my dad's
always had the saying which is form is
temporary class is permanent you know
and I think that that that kind of
epitomizes what you're talking about
there and you you write as well the fact
that it is so easy for people on the
internet to throw shade like anyone can
criticize because you have to build it
at law of entropy right it's much easier
break something that is to build it well
you know you guys this thing going on
little brexit right now what's
everyone's talking about right and it's
it's it is easy to be an opposition
party it's much easier it's much more
difficult to go in and work at a an
organizational level or systems level
well you can come in and do your
grassroots guerrilla I'm special this is
my secret school program but I'm gonna
be more interested in when you start to
to take a swing at improving from the
top down and at the whole thing you know
and and I think it's really it's crucial
that you know you can show your
associations and that your models work
across cohorts so this this is an
you know this is someone else's thinking
but a good model as explanatory explains
what you're saying it's predictive it
predicts what's gonna happen and it's
repeatable right you can communicate it
and so if I watch some one teacher coach
does it explain what I'm seeing is a
predict what's gonna happen if this
person runs or muj at speed or under
load and can lots of coaches communicate
it and understand it you know so we
start with that and then the other the
other pieces for me it's got a hold true
that I don't teach children one thing an
Olympic athlete - the other thing it's
all continuum of skill and ability of
complexity that you know the things that
I'm working on you every human being you
know the flex and extend their spine
right and if I everyone should be able
to run and cut and jump and play frisbee
and so if I'm teaching one skill for
fitness but another skill for actual
expression of fitness then that ends up
being a really confusing idea so we need
to be able to explain phenomena across
cohorts across ages across templates and
because the Internet has connected so
many coaches and so many so many movers
we can see what first principles are and
more importantly we can see what first
positions are what first patterns are
and then that's got to be mutually
accommodative right on top of what the
physiology says is a better expression
of the position and it's got to explain
gymnastics and it's got to explain
what's a good thing it's gotta explain
running and swimming and what's nice
about that is this the same shoulder
over the last 10,000 years people been
thinking critically about getting more
out of the human body for as long as
they've been here as we are obsessed
with being better than ourselves and we
always have them alexander invaded we're
invaded Afghanistan and like 50 BC like
are you telling me that they weren't
talking about food and logistics and
paying people dude people have been
sophisticated for a long time and just
because we're modern and we have this
internet and like you and I are talking
to each other via sorcery doesn't mean
that someone hasn't been thinking about
how to go faster so you know when you
drop into yoga wow this is really clever
yeah Joseph Joseph Pilates wasn't
[ __ ] around and if he was still
around today
he would advance his practice you know
so when you see a system or methodology
that is stuck in tradition and doesn't
take into information and can translate
then you it may be valuable but you know
for me man I wish I had I wish had 50
Russian stem units they're great but I
don't and that doesn't scale when I'm
working with a bunch of teams and that
doesn't scale so so now for me it's
valuable to say hey does this hold true
and then can i shape my thinking up and
down same principles to talk about
public health at Google to talk about
low back pain at Google why why do we
have to say it's totally okay to have
crappy posture and postures fine and
pushes even matter you can do whatever
you want I'm like until you need to swim
or take a breath or rotate or throw a
ball and put your arms over your head so
why don't we just make that your base
position the position of being a more
functional human being right sure you
can do that you can be a demi person and
I'm not even talking about pain I'm
talking about output and function so
quit you know there's no more complex
structure in the known universe than the
human brain that's it it's you have a
Brit there named Adam Rutherford who is
the greatest writer about genetics and
that's his phrase the human body the
human brain is the most complex
structure in the known universe attached
to a physiology that is robust and
tolerant and and designed for survival
and adaptation but we've got to get
beyond it's okay now because it doesn't
hurt and it's not costing me anything
into are you gonna be 100 years old and
you're gonna be stuck bent cuz thats
that [ __ ] sucks that's what's gonna
happen and and it'll be too late for me
to be like told you 50 years ago told
you have you watched the game changes
documentary no but I have had a lot of
conversations about it right okay have
you got any intention to watch it yeah
you know we should watch it because I
think one of the things that we're
seeing right now is people are very you
know nutrition comes very confusing I
just read an article about that Chris
Crestor put up about just being keto
right and and and carnivore based and I
think what's interesting when you look
our traditions we've always eaten plants
and whatever very protein sources are
available to us I think the human being
is tolerant to be able to burn whatever
it wants to use whatever it wants I
think that what we've seen is that
people love to go Kito or karna more
because they can be lazy again and then
just take supplements to make themselves
better right and so if I if I am having
to exercise and then I have to do all
the supplemental work there may be some
issues with my movement practice if I'm
eating a certain way but don't get
enough B vitamins or essential fats and
I have to add them in with a pill that
can be another thing we also need to
separate out potential drug use and
anabolic use we need to separate out and
not always use contacts so these store
open contacts if you imagine what the
quality of meet wise when the gladiators
are fighting and maybe they found out
that in get sick in that context so
we're like all gladiators don't eat meat
you know think about the Rome and meat
population problem right so I think
what's interesting if you look at King
Shanahan and her book nutrition you'll
see that there are fundamental
principles the way people eat and have
always been so I think you can turn up
and down the dials of how much protein
you need it's difficult you you know I
you know the fastest way people are like
Kelly I need to lose weight like I need
to lose muscle right we get this
conversation so nice and I know that's
madness well I was gonna say who is that
give it to me so you're too big and I'm
like no problem here's what you're gonna
do you're gonna become a vegan and I'm
gonna get you on a bike and we're gonna
bike 2 hours a day they're gonna be a
vegan
and I guarantee you you will blow
through your musculature very quickly on
that that regimen and now we have all
these protein powders and processed
foods that allow us to have multi
protein sources that are vegetarian
based ultimately though absolutely a
choice like religion to eat the way you
want but what you're gonna see is that
people have been eating awful for a long
time not eating meat right not eating
the flesh of animals we've been eating
the animal itself we eat organs we
connective tissue
we don't eat steaks right so something's
we're there we eat the whole animal you
eat the brain you eat the eyes eat the
organs right
the bones eat the marrow you ate all of
the you know plant matter you can get
into your hands what was available to
you and you'll start to see is that we
awful we drink whole milk dairy if it's
available to us you know we kick out
meat on the bone we don't you know we
try to get as many different kinds of
vegetables as you can and so when you
come in imagine that you have an athlete
who's been eating protein shakes and in
and out burgers and sausage rolls and
all of a sudden they start adding a ton
of plant matter to their diet and guess
what happens they feel better gut bound
turns on energy goes up they lose weight
because they're not eating these
calorically dense processed foods
they're even plants again that seems
pretty reasonable to me
but then I'd say let's put our money
where our ethics is and our you know if
you're a 22 year old kid trying to
survive you may be able only to afford
the really cheap eggs and the the bags
of frozen chicken which is like I'll put
in quotation marks chicken right as you
get older you were like hey I can put my
money into this this animal that has a
name is pastured right that is
sustainably sourced that I'm closer to
my meat I eat from this like there's a
whole lot of variability there so I
think when it proves this man are we
eating as well as we're eating you know
what is the basis and then the second
thing is I need to see what the
experiment looks like at 20 years 30
years or 40 years right and I'm gonna
need to see your blood panels because
I'll tell you that most vegetarian teams
are headed by the body like and
carbohydrates and your a1c is off and
you're like my plant-based diet is great
and meanwhile your testosterone is in
the tanker your IGF looks terrible your
B vitamin deficient vitamin D is shite
right I mean let's let's make sure that
we're actually measuring and I can apply
that same rubric to your standard
American diet or your I eat plants with
a little bit of protein diet right so
what you'll see is that the rules are
the same and the thing that we're really
careful about saying is that hey there
is variability in human basis your squat
width and my squat width is a little
different my torso comes for a little
bit more
your torches lit more upright when we
front squat based on our anthropometry
your genetics a little different if I
just ain't fat all the time I would be a
disaster I would have disaster pants my
blood pressure
I just don't handle all the saturated
fats and my friends do or Italian right
so let's just say that there are first
principles always and I think it's
absolutely a good thing to try to more
diversity our friend kitchen hand points
out that you know we used to probably
close to forty to sixty kinds of
vegetables and fruits in a year and I'll
ask you can you name twenty vegetables
no when's the last time five different
kinds of vegetables and what you're
seeing is holy [ __ ] what we're doing is
we're saying brown rice and broccoli and
assessing the chicken breast is the
answer to nutrition and performance and
all the sudden what we saw was that men
were missing all the micro nutrient
density so if you move to a plant-based
system
fantastic we eat enough protein to
signal correctly do you need I mean I
can see where they're coming from the
byproducts that sometimes the detriment
ation of eating all of this meat may not
be the best thing for you right it has a
consequence we used to have this I use
me professional packer and we had the
stove in college that we'd cook on and
it was called the MSR International and
it was a diesel white gas kerosene and
one time we were like it says it burns
these let's do diesel so we turn on
black smoke because just roiling
everywhere like it's just charred
everything and the jet clogged so we've
taken apart clear it out turn it back on
noodles our ramen smells like smoke just
shake we're like oh it can burn diesel
it just shouldn't burn diesel and I
think if you realize how tolerant the
human genome is then there are a lot of
ways in test-retest you need to show me
your blood panels we need to talk about
what this looks like over the long haul
and i think you absolutely can be vegan
and absolutely huge changes have to be
very disciplined about it fantastic
great I mean you need to show me your
work the problem is the problem is that
all of the things that we're doing
whether it be to do with training
whether it be to do with nutrition
whether it be to do with our mindset and
the way that we structure our
there is such a gap between the cause of
whatever your choices and the effect
down the road and that vacuum that gas
exactly where charlatans are able to
move in and potentially commercialize or
monetize that's also where
disinformation can go in that's where
social campaigns can garner momentum and
also to stuff everything that we've
actually spoken about today whether it's
from a strength and conditioning
perspective whether it's from a more
holistic mobility side whether it's the
diet all of these things are very very
complex and people have different goals
what I want out of my training in my
diet might be different to you somebody
else
100 percent and and I think when we come
back to first principles and then we can
say you know if you you're like I he'll
strike this feel striking is the best
when I run great don't change it that's
totally okay nobody use your court and
you're so fast but you have to come out
unharmed at 20 years at 30 years if all
of a sudden you have destructed heal
cords and you're injured and your heel
bone is terrible and your back is and
you can't run anymore then like maybe we
should think differently about that
experiment and and that is that is
difficult right and it's difficult for
us to see inputs and outputs so someone
wants super plant-based and then they
stop going super plant-based would you
say that I failed that right because it
didn't work for them how would we know
so I'm like how do I measure or keto all
right so ultimately you know it's
difficult for us to say inputs and
outputs because we have people haven't
eaten in this way for a long time you
know or people who have been vegans for
a long time aren't really really strong
you know necessarily you know those
those populations do different things
and you know I think it's it's okay to
look at the variability the human being
and say where am I
what are the best choices I can make
what are the ethical considerations but
again if we're talking about optimal
let's cut you in half let's count the
Rings so slick your blood panels let's
look at how well you're managing and
your tissue health and what I can
unequivocally say about this topic is
that I don't think you're eating enough
vegetables this period and show me when
you are show me when you've had
too many no and if you know you know one
of our friends said and this is very
crass but you watch a television show
about a super lean morbidly obese person
who's been filled by society they're
taking down a wall to wheel a person off
what person is surrounded by processed
foods not apples and bananas not heads
of lettuce and so you know to the extent
that we are trying to say this is better
and I think I think that's very
reasonable if you want to pull back on
your meat consumption up your plants how
did your performance go oh you're just
lifting in the gym because that's not
performance you know our how many of my
Olympic athletes around the metal stand
on those diets and I'm saying that died
I'm saying that eating I haven't talked
I met many of them right do they need as
much protein as like point seven grams
per pound you know that those are
different conversations right so tuning
up between them does that hold true
across cohorts so as I age up I lose my
muscle mass my signaling comes down
joining me more for today less protein
because I'm my signaling has come down
as I've gotten older right am i engaging
weight bearing what about sarcopenia so
if I'm micronutrient dense I said to
have my body's gonna protect clotting
mechanisms more than my bone growth
right so on muscle growth so we said to
see osteoporosis we start to see a whole
bunch of other things show up so it's
difficult for us to say inputs and
outputs we have to do is look at what
our new traditions have been what are
the overlaps and then let's start
running the experiment but let's
actually make an experiment not about
value I think everyone gets so tribal
and emotive about this right that's okay
that's all right so I'm like great I'll
see you I'll see you on the medicine I
see it is the water it's it's good it's
hilarious to watch but it doesn't help
us come up with what is the effective
solution and it is we were we were in
New York and we started thing called the
pig in that it wasn't a being advertised
so what pagan diet okay
hey leo oh okay plant-based diet with
small amounts of animal protein and we
were like you mean food you know so one
of my friends is a woman named EC Santos
key and she's optimized me nutrition and
she has this notion
first things first let's improve the
caloric density of your diet by getting
you to eat 800 grams of vegetables and
fruits a day 800 grams just hit that
mark look me so that's how far away
we're having a conversation about is
this movie about being plant-based good
or bad I'm like hey I eat meat and eggs
and cheese and all these other things
but I also get 800 grams of vegetables
and fruits or a kilo of vigils of fruits
a day that's my base are you able to are
you able to stick to around the piece of
cake but I have to have side salad for
breakfast I a palm full of blueberries
is 80 grams so what you're seeing is oh
you know we we villainized fruit right
yeah I'm like seriously you think and at
like eating two apples is really the
limiting factor to your performance
today what are you gonna eat instead you
know like a protein shake a highly
processed impossible burger so there's a
lot of ways where we can start to
improve density and improve quality but
um you know let me know how that goes
for it you know when you start eating it
you know so you oh you're plant-based oh
that means you're drinking plant-based
shakes that's not food that's a food
like product so let me see you go to
town and eat massive plates full of
vegetables and massive amounts of fruit
and massive amounts of good grains and
massive amounts of high-quality fats and
maybe you need to supplement with some
fish collagen because holy [ __ ] you're
not getting any connective tissue in
your diet and that's a problem if you're
an athlete right so that's okay you're
allowed to eat and live and sleep as
little as much as you want you can't
make the statement but this is the best
way for children to develop or the best
way especially when I'm like hey you
know yeah mom you're so right so one
thing I wanted to finish on we've
touched on the word first principles a
few times today if you were to talk
about the first principles that you aim
to have a holistic life from overall do
you have a number of first principles
that you try and stick to so a guiding a
guiding rule set that you try and have
in your mind at all times Julian and I
protect our sleep like it's our job
it's the most important thing we we
control what we control we protect our
sleep and we just prioritize prep for
ourselves and our children because we
see that that is that's the game we stop
drinking predominantly because what we
found was that really affected our sleep
and we also had to show our family our
kids that like we didn't need alcohol to
come down and have fun or write and dude
some pools of great ball and why not
well the bus right right right you know
an amazing show we're gonna have a vodka
tonic it's that's okay right but what
you'll see is that we've gone to
drinking twice a month you know because
we we were like hey this really has a
huge cost are sleeping our performance
and so we start to realize that hey I
can start to begin to organize my
thinking around protecting my sleep so
for example when this first faint smell
I don't I personally don't drink
caffeine after four o'clock because it
will mess up my sleep I'll sleep I just
want sleep as well and so you know we
started doing a lot of our soft tissue
mobilization just simply rolling out
foam rolling ball stuff before me what's
about why because it caused us to relax
and to sleep better so suddenly you know
we all see eye masks and earplugs in our
house I don't see what earplugs I want
to hear the all the fights and all the
scary stuff but everyone else I mask the
air plugs in a pitch dark cold room
because it's about protecting the
quality of sleep so suddenly you start
to see this organization around sleep as
a first principle Juliet and I try to
walk 12,000 steps a day in addition to
our training because it takes that much
to load to cumulate enough fatigue to
decongest after the loading that we're
doing so the same way that we're saying
to people hey you can't just eat protein
shakes and balance bars and bulletproof
coffee and pretend like there's coffee
has no micronutrients and it's 700
calories like you've got to be [ __ ]
kidding let's make a decision right so
the same way we're thinking about that
we're thinking about you know movement
so if you're going to the gym and
slamming yourself but then you're
sedentary the rest of the day I
guarantee you you're not decongestant
unloading and Reaper fusing and and
moving your tissues enough you're gonna
get stiff your tea or not you're asking
look right why because humans have to
move so however you want to get that and
if you live in a city believe it or not
you may be
getting your steps just because you live
in a city could be that the meaning in
the city is is more important than like
driving in your car frontier country
house so all of a sudden that we start
we start to organize ourselves our own
vegetables and fruits that is this the
primary organization of our eating
vegetables and fruits plus the best
available protein that's you know that
we can afford and then you know then
things start to layer in so you'll
notice that I said sleep and move and
vegetables and proteins and holy crap
that's not sexy that's free and you can
control that and on days where I can't
train
I still move my body still protected my
sleep so when it's time to go I can go
and really that's that's what we're
trying to see is that hey let's not make
these lists let's control we can control
and then if you want to drink drinking
your own vacation drink when you're not
stressed don't drink when you're
stressed out and training hard don't you
know don't don't sacrifice your sleep
because you're watching Netflix protect
that [ __ ] especially if we're talking
about going the distance couldn't agree
moment couldn't agree more I'm now 15
months sober because I wanted to see if
I could do 18 months in an industry
where everybody drinks and I wanted more
time I wanted my sleep to be best and
the listeners will know that they've
heard this story a million times but
it's it's the single best upgrade that I
think most people in the 21st century
can give themselves is to having a
sustained period of sobriety with a
reason for doing it go ahead and just
test retest how you feel as you sleep
how'd your body composition go as your
mental acuity we realize tasty tasty
poison and one of the reasons we call so
important to us in the past as it was
safe that alcohol wasn't poisonous you
could mix water and rum water and wine
you knew that that was safe it was a
important storable way to say grain the
strength grapes right it was you know
imagine you know I'm just saying that it
has its utility we maybe don't need this
utility as much and you know and when
you start to track those things
especially if the thing you care about
is going faster and lifting more you're
like hey that's gonna have to come in a
choice the same way this chocolate cake
is and what we try to have people do is
I'm gonna look
is chocolate cake a problem no Jean
chocolate cake every day you start
eating chocolate cakes at 11 o'clock
like you do Pimm's Cup in the summer no
like you know so you don't start eating
it like let's have a brunch and starting
chocolate cake every hour on the hour
for the next 14 hours that's crazy right
and so you know again don't take our
word for it this is on you
test-retest do you feel better are you
happy with the way you feel great do you
look great naked are you planning on
being 100
what are those best practices and it
turns out that the performance community
how do I meet Kate Shanahan the
physician who's talking about food
because I work with her with the Lakers
right because those are the those are
the eating recommendations she put in
into high-performance basketball I love
it man Kelly today has been absolutely
fantastic and for the listeners who want
to check out more where should they go
now where's the hub for all things Kelly
today we are at the ready state and you
can see how we coach and think on the
Instagram we've got a couple podcasts
ourselves we we don't we're not like you
or not prolific we have a season
something we're interested in then we
could sound for a while you know we
talked about crime scene we talked about
kids you know so we've talked about the
history of CrossFit a little bit you
know all things you know we ended up
having to care about sleep and hydration
and walking and nutrition and stress
because well why your tissues sucked and
why you so stiff bro you know because
because you're living in some kind of
you know demi-human state so I think
that's really ultimately we're saying is
we can't strip out the your your knee
capsule or your hamstring stiffness from
the way your existing in the world we
better talk to our smart friends who are
experts in those things so we're at the
race it come see how we coach coming out
with us awesome I'm sure that you will
have a number of people who are very
interested to find out how it was what's
going on
final thing what's what's happening for
you next what's next on your schedule if
you got anything coming up that's going
to be cool you got to two big teams
playing against each other at the moment
what else well you know let's see you
know phase one at the ready stage one of
the things that were really great about
we're stoked on this you have two weeks
of trying it out and
teach you how to mobilize in those two
weeks so if you've never mobilized or
thought hey I should do something that
what are my positions enough come on
board for two weeks and in those two
weeks we'll show you how it works and
we'll show you what the thinking is
canceled after two weeks and already
you've had a free education we're gonna
come to Asia our face - we just have a
lot planned you know there's another
edition of sup a leopard coming around
the corner eventually they're smarter
and if we were still saying the exact
same thing we said six years ago we
should be alarmed if you if you're not
seeing the court principal say the same
but the application the principal's
being being involved then you know you
should you should run the other way
couldn't agree more
Kelly today's been awesome everyone that
is listening all that we've talked about
will be linked in the show notes below
of course go and check out the ready
state any questions comments or feedback
leave them in the comments below I'll
get at me at Chris will X on all social
media or get at the ready state and
hassle Kerry and Kelley you'll have to
ill have to come on in and reply to some
DMS or something like that
Kelley it's been awesome I hope you have
a really good day one thanks brother
appreciate you guys
[Music]